what was different about the squid game
video what did you tap into that
I think that's just uh well there's a
lot of things because a it was a mega
Giga crazy Trend but that was also the
first video we ever used CGI when I was
like I I most spent like two million
dollars on a video up to that point that
one we spent 4.2 million so like we took
it was like a mega [ __ ] Ultra trend
supercharged with our biggest budget
ever I we scrapped all our videos when
all hands on deck 30 minutes of just
everything I poured my heart and soul
into it and like that I think it was
just like a right combination of
everything more money more effort more
time super Trend stir it all together
which I don't understand why more people
don't do that make it part of the
content so it's not boring yeah yeah and
how was that day like that day this the
school game video comes out you push
publish oh what is the next like 12
hours it's crazy because like that month
we gained on just the English Channel 9
million subscribers no actually I think
we gained 10 million subscribers Jesus
yeah [ __ ] crazy across all the
platforms that month we gained like 25
million his [ __ ] warm hand was warm
like most views uh on a single YouTube
video in a day did you know within the
first hour you were like this oh 100
yeah before you posted it oh yeah uh
before I had a so what I did there which
I don't normally do is I was hyping it
up on Tick Tock which actually worked
really well so like I was showing the
sets before yeah that's true you've
never did a promo really exactly because
like I don't know but that one we were
just so [ __ ] balls deep money spent
like I needed this to do well or I'm
[ __ ] yeah yeah this is like Ben the
farm on the video so we were like
showing the sets giving people hype and
like we were getting 30 million views on
a tick tock just like of people just
showing them parts of the video not even
showing the contestants just like hey
look what we built and they were like
exploded so like by the time we uploaded
there were like millions of people on
the channel just like refreshing waiting
for it to go live and there are like
people begging for us to drop the video
so which that worked really well it was
like that's the thing like spoon game
was us doing everything perfect with a
giga Trend it's going to be damn near
impossible to like recreate all that
like every Factor just a perfect video
with the print with the perfect height
with the perfect everything like I don't
even know like in I don't know how we
did it 45 days it was [ __ ] hell 150
people working on that video it was like
[ __ ] crazy yeah even like um so and
we were pulling on every connection I
had like we had different YouTubers like
we put squibs on them these devices so
we could kill them by popping This and
like so like that connected to like the
Wi-Fi Center and this giant stadium that
we're doing the red light green light
but the first day we went to film the
Wi-Fi crashed there's too many there
um and then
um we reboot it and now certain phones
are dying [ __ ] hell so I gave
everyone who came out a thousand dollars
all 456 000 of them I was like hey stop
all right so that's why I went from 3.5
million to 4.2 because yeah because
basically like we had to re-upgrade the
system in the stadium to handle 456
individual devices so we could kill them
456 000 yeah so I gave them all Grand I
was like all right just come back in the
morning you could have given them 500
you know that right yeah oh well
um I just and then so we did that and so
that threw on more and this was like all
these um it's actually supposed to be a
two million dollar video that turned
into 4.2 million and that's when I was
like 2 million was already crazy yeah
and I'm like [ __ ] by the end of it I'm
just like bro this doesn't Crush game
cost what the show uh I think it was
like 9 million right wow and that was
tennis
mine was like a 25 minute video look at
the ROI bro that is insane so but yeah
but it's because like yeah
[Laughter]
it was it was a lot man because we were
like we're also in bump [ __ ] nowhere so
there's not Studio space I love that you
stayed in North Carolina one of the
negatives of North Carolina is there's
not Studios infrastructure yeah so it's
not like I can just go rent a bunch of
like Studios so I'm like oh the
wrestling green light was like in a
rodeo station where they're like [ __ ]
Wrangle cows and [ __ ] if they're like
clear up the animals we need a [ __ ]
set here and then we're like uh any
churches here with open because there's
a lot of churches in North Carolina not
a lot of warehouses yeah
um and so you know you find like a
church here for a set and then you like
we have our big studio and you do sets
here and like we're like scraping the
barrel to find like space to build all
this [ __ ]
um and then yeah and then like you have
to build the infrastructure for the
Wi-Fi just even that system man was so
crazy we had to build a custom which I
didn't obviously we hired people like
William Osmond other people built a
custom app so it has all the numbers of
the players so I can tap and kill them
when they die so like their squib
explodes yeah we also have to make sure
the squib doesn't light on fire and
that's it's crazy man all this in 45
days while building these sets will also
doing CGI for the first time and like
yeah I mean I just like I was terrified
that's what I was thinking I was
watching I was like there's no way that
one of these didn't [ __ ] light on
fire or something happened because you
actually have like a mini yeah explosion
yeah it was yeah it was smoking that's
how we got the real effects yeah it was
uh I think it was red at first and I was
like [ __ ] it like clicked like before we
were about to film I was like we can't
have blood we're fine which is why we
switched the color yeah
um it was so much so between that which
we've never done before in our custom
app and the wi-fi system and these crazy
sets like walls like taller than I've
ever seen before plus like you know the
top of it's a stadium and when we're
filming they're like you know we're just
gonna turn it into blue sky like squid
game we're just gonna CGM I'm like what
the [ __ ] is does that mean you're just
we're just gonna CG this room that was
your CGI was the roof yeah all
everything man it was [ __ ] and I'd
never done this any before so I was just
losing my goddamn mind left and right
because where the [ __ ] that's right oh
yeah there we go I like that you did 456
too yeah yeah well because I couldn't
afford to do more
oh my God the [ __ ] this is zooming
um this is bad for attention so yeah
this that Sky up there is not real
starting at the end of the blue is all
CGI yeah all CGI we're in a studio what
we did was we took the lights so we had
to install a grid system and we angled
the lights in a way where it was looking
like it came from a sun so all the
lights came from a certain direction to
mimic the Sun
but
wow yeah and then obviously those
explosions are real yeah
hey Carl
OS
[Music]
they're all so quiet it made me feel so
weird standing in front of all these
people why they didn't talk yeah because
it's like I don't know they're just they
were all just staring at me it made me
feel uncomfortable do you know if any of
the people that came hadn't seen squid
game yet oh quite a few yeah I think I'm
coming up I asked one of them and they
say that where is she
oh yeah that girl she never saw yeah
she's playing the main character and she
had never seen her
hilarious oh that's crazy and what is
this day like you wake up this is your
Super Bowl you spent five million
dollars on us everything what is the
pregame ritual that you have well I mean
well should we do this but this is the
second time we did it because the first
time we had to you know fix the routers
and everything but like do you sleep
like okay I need eight hours I know we
were dying we were all dying wow that
was that was a lot that was that was the
hardest thing our team's ever done I
mean I was just we're I mean look at all
those people in those red suits palette
around the side yeah I mean like
everything man like 150 people were
working on this video I just those were
the most hectic 45 days of my entire
existence one of the red suits is just a
home team or somebody uh probably like a
day higher the we just I well this was
the second day so the second day I think
we literally just pulled in people like
anyone that knew anyone I just needed
people because we ran out of people to
pull front wow yeah and what is your
mood like on a day like this would you
would you consider yourself so stressed
are you easy to work with uh I'm not
talking to many people like I'm
obsessing over like how do we get this
the retention good what like you know
like what do I say you have one shot for
a lot of exactly this I can't redo if I
don't like this is a real uh countdown
going and if I don't like it there's
nothing I can do about it after I feel
that's the big thing with a lot of our
videos is because they're not scripted
like if there's like a moment where it's
like hit the shot you make a million
dollars if you don't get the shot I have
to pay the guy whether or not he makes
it you know I have to pay the guy if he
makes it so like if we don't film it
properly there's no like oh the cameras
weren't right yeah you're pretty intense
are you ever yelling at people like
after the video do you have to be like
hey I'm sorry about that oh no no
obviously not I mean it'd be dumb if I
yelled at people um so you're just calm
though folks just try yelling bro that
[ __ ] works
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's pretty
effective wait what is good if nothing
else oh yeah what's some of the other CG
he's just doing this so we can flag the
interview if he doesn't like it yeah
remember I like going through this while
he's here this oh yeah where's the [ __ ]
is this mouse bro you guys gonna get a
better setup this is annoying come on
dude
what is the Spike oh I know yeah where
the [ __ ] is a wide shot so
like none of this oh that's all blue
screen all this background is like CG oh
really yeah well this is black okay here
oh what yeah like all that is blue
screen uh actually black screen uh the
earlier one is blue so this was just
basically what we did was it got this
black mat just super black that doesn't
reflect light and then that's our studio
so it's like a wall covered in all black
it's a super big studio and then the
floor is covered in all black and then
they just lowered the floor and then
added poles so it's like yeah yeah I
don't prefer I didn't know what the [ __ ]
I was doing I was just praying it looked
good this this was all blue screen none
of that's real so I'm also like bro this
is gonna be horseshit so we're standing
in front of just these blue screens and
they took this and like um cg'd it down
oops down here so what the [ __ ] oh yeah
see down there right below the foam pit
yeah that thing's there so it's like for
I didn't even know what these guys were
talking about so crispy are the goats
the people who worked on it so we're in
a different room blue screen in front of
these things pick the balls and they're
like yeah we're just gonna put it below
the foam pit that's in that [ __ ]
Warehouse covered in this and then we're
gonna put these spikes here and and I
was like there's just no [ __ ] this is
Two Shots come on top of each other
it's crazy and I'm literally I'm losing
my mind I'm looking at him I'm like
Micah you're [ __ ] crazy if you think
this is gonna look good just you're just
gonna magically stack these shots and
one of these shots is just straight up a
[ __ ] blue screen this is one of the
most impressive Parts oh yeah it's the
altitude and I was like how yeah I was
just wondering hey can you put your hand
on that TV go up to the on the left and
go up higher so right there everything
below that is not real so we built that
wow everything above it now move it to
the right uh move it to the right right
there that is real yeah that's the
people outside the studio standing in
front of blue screens and they're they
cj8 in so this is the last one but in
the earlier ones there's tons of people
there so huh they're like they're bro
they're [ __ ] I don't know how is that
feeling giving up all that control he's
terrified terrified I was like I was
certain this is just going to turn out
horseshit you'd see like shitty green
screen you know whatever yeah they
pulled through
um I felt a little bit better after we
finished there was like a team of like
30 people or something crazy just in
there we had we took one of our rooms
and converted it to just a giant editing
room yeah and once they were just like
going ham I was like okay now I feel a
little they were supremely confident
when they were speaking to you about it
yeah they were they were which is why
it's great working with professionals
because I don't know [ __ ] yeah they're
like oh no this will be great and I'm
like what the [ __ ]
um I was like this just doesn't feel
good like how how how I'd look over and
be like this is 10 feet in there he's
like yeah I'm like but in the video it's
500 feet he's like yeah it's like how
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he'd be like
that white shot over there all right
more more stuff from this video sorry
we're hurting how many views no no uh
probably just shy of well English or
everything English and then everything
uh 280 English probably 400 everything
280 is almost a population of America uh
yeah
this this scene wasn't that crazy
um we gave them the bag of marbles they
do it this I don't know a lot of them
were very dramatic which is cool it's
good content uh some of them it just
didn't even feel real because some of
them would play it up I feel like you
don't have to yeah yeah then the ad I
don't know was there anything else yeah
oh the [ __ ] glass Bridge yes this was
look at that this this also doubled uh
no that's so everything below the the
foam pit was basically sitting on the
ground and it uh oh wait no no so the um
what is it the tug of war one yep was
just sitting on top of that and then
when we went and filmed in the other
studio for the marbles here they were
pulling the road off of it and
underneath it was this so we built tug
of war on top of that top of it yeah
that's why it looks similar yeah yeah
yeah uh but then we just put that foam
pit down but below the foam pit is it's
not real it's not real yeah unbelievable
but so the you jumped you do fall in a
real foam pit and then everything below
we just did it to make it look more
dramatic and then like these shots are
[ __ ] crazy
oh my God like I don't know how they
[ __ ] did it look at that [ __ ] yeah so
that's why I did well because like I
don't I don't even I don't even know how
we did this
this is [ __ ] wild and it was
genuinely terrifying when those things
fell through yeah like yeah it's crazy
how this played out like it did in the
show yeah yeah because they just actual
psychology of it was the same point no
you could jump skip me I took the risk
on this one you do it on 100 and I tried
not to influence it too much so like
yeah how much do you coach the actual
contestants I mean I was telling them
but they had the full authority to do
whatever they want so I'd be like hey
you should really go time's running out
and they better okay have you ever had
that where contestant just Bosh the
video oh all the time really it's
annoying like sometimes you'll give
someone 100 Grand and they'll just be
like thanks and I'll be like anything
else you want to say and I know like if
they don't say something please have a
dying mom please
anytime I upload a video where someone's
like doesn't freak out people in the
comments are like oh it's fake and
there's just all these conspiracy
theories and everyone's like certain
like if I won 100 Grand I wouldn't react
the only explanation for why they
wouldn't freak out is Mr B's fix it not
that this is an introvert or anything
that's why part of the uh Buried Alive
video I didn't believe because you
didn't seem scared oh really
bro yeah but I'm like anybody in that
position would be like yeah why didn't
you keep the footage of you being stuck
man I just you didn't think it worked in
the video no I just like I don't want to
scare people just like my biggest thing
is I knew factually I was safe and I
didn't want to by the extent I don't
want to deceive you man so I didn't want
people to think I wasn't in a safe
position because I knew like I'd freak
out but then I'd calm myself down by
being like this is it we've tested it we
spent half a million dollars making this
[ __ ] coffin I know I'm fine but then
if I didn't portray that and people
thought I could die then I'm a reckless
YouTuber oh he put his [ __ ] life on
the point
um yeah but this part at the end was
crazy
uh like I don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on here
like right here I'm like losing my mind
I'm like guys like if
and I kept saying to trick like if
everyone gets out here like there is
just no winner yeah then I was like I
was turning around but I was like tweak
but if there's no winner they're gonna
think I rigged this to save money this
is gonna be blue ball there has to be a
winner but I can't rig it I was like
what the [ __ ] did I do instead of 10
seconds and none of them are jumping uh
yeah then I came down to here
and yeah a bunch of them got out
I was freaking out here too I was like
God damn it like now let's make that
after the story like yeah you know
because none of them whatever but it
ended up working out no one cared we
just all the people who were still on
there at zero seconds got it you got
yeah yeah wow and then the very end
instead of a knife fight you do musical
chairs musical chairs what other options
did you have where you were like okay we
can't do the knife fight what else can
we do yeah I just I like simplicity so
everyone knows how to play musical
chairs I could have made it more
advanced but
you know we knew this would get a couple
hundred million views and so the more
complicated it is the less you have to
explain the game exactly I hate exactly
like ideally things are just like
implicit you keep the rhythm going yeah
oh that's yeah I would say one criticism
about squid game is the last game I
still don't know but people but
obviously they made it for Koreans who
do understand of course of course but it
would be nice since we're watching yeah
you just [ __ ] predict your show's
gonna blow up in America yeah why did
you do that what the [ __ ] see the future
with your unlimited money God damn it
I mean wow you had the right title you
had a good job